first time I ever met Arnold that I
recall he was eating out of a garbage
can and I said come on seriously let me
buy a hogy or submarine sandwich he goes
no no I'm really happy with leftover
Chinese food no problem then the second
time I met him was at the Golden Globe
Awards I'll never forget I said who is
this hulking guy he goes oh and it was
read best newcomer Arnold schwartzen go
as what piano mover no actor I had no
idea and then I looked at him he's very
kind guy and we're kind of competitive I
can feel this thing going on and on so
he wins best newcomer I went wow why am
I even here and I'm sitting there and
between us is this giant bouquet of
flowers and when they announced Rocky as
best picture I took the flowers and
threw them in the air and as fate would
have it the majority landed on Arnold